what about this we were talking about
this last week if you're stranded on an
island and your partner died if Tony
died would you eat his body to keep you
alive I mean the logical side of me
wants to say yes because I think that's
the right thing to do I think that's
what he would want me to do yes but if
it actually came down to it I don't know
that I could he's upset because I would
legit eat him if he would he wouldn't he
wouldn't eat kalila he wouldn't meet me
he would just let my body rot and waste
because if I'm at that point right where
you and I are left on an island you die
right and I eat you and then what
happens a week later I'm dead anyway
no okay also I get saved in an hour yeah
I'm on a boat I go what I would do is I
would literally like freezer pack all I
mean vacuum seal yeah so that I could
have meat for months I would chop them
up efficiently in the first days dry it
like jerky some of it yeah yeah oh
cure it but you and I saltwater from the
sea but you got it you got to make a
decision quickly because the meat will
go bad especially if it in the tropical
area so you have to think quick like am
I gonna eat him or am I not gonna eat
him you can't deliberate and sit on it
for a week all right I'm gonna say this
though all right if you eat me and then
you 40 years later you die I'll be up in
the pearly gates I'm gonna I'm gonna win
I'm a problem so you don't even want her
to eat you that I sell fish yeah you
want me to die really self oh whoa I'm
gonna turn the tables on saying like for
what reason
not one her to eat he's already useless
to himself I wouldn't eat her I I want
him to eat me I want you I don't want to
eat you like your [ __ ] how would you
eat my [ __ ] when I'm dead but not alive
you don't let me eat her [ __ ] the
[ __ ] eye begins to oscillate did the
last time this is what you call his
romance he's on top of me
he thinks he's sort he thinks he were
making out and then he
pauses and then pulls his long strand of
fish guts out his gums and he flicks it
like over the bed like this like a
sailor like a sailor and he thinks that
that's somehow like romantic and we're
supposed to proceed sex therapist also
what do you think that's pretty gross
okay that's a style style I wouldn't say
it's romantic love pure love love on
Netflix yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]